[Musique]
salut vous demandez sûrement comment
j'en suis arrivée là et surtout vous
voulez savoir pourquoi
ben c'est normal c'est le principe du
teasing vous accrocher dès le début et
vous allez découvrir le pourquoi du
comment mais un conseil soyez très
attentifs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'aller
voir un truc incroyable c'est un endroit
incroyable évidemment je vous emmène
avec moi mais je vous donner quelques
indices sur la route essayer de trouver
ce que c'est attention le premier indice
c'est quelque chose d'un peu complexe on
va dire ce qu'on va voir quelque chose
qui peut casser la la cabeza pas trop
dur
deuxième indice si on arrive à l'ouvrir
on remporte beaucoup d'argent et là vous
vous dites non c'est pas possible c'est
pas le cube de diamants et bien si il ya
le cube désir manqué exposé en ce moment
même à paris et j'ai la chance de
pouvoir des devoirs de pouvoir vous
montrer et en plus ils ont privatisé le
moment donc on va pouvoir s'éclater au
tour c'est incroyable
loïc génériques ah bah non théologue
[Musique]
salut bonjour je pense que c'est vous
que j'ai eu au téléphone en thani oui
enchanté monsieur li carte olicard merci
beaucoup de m'accueillir de me laisser
bien filmé cet objet de fou en fait
marié pas de quoi tout le plaisir est
pour moi sébastien fabien anthony alors
je m'appelle fabien evry
[Musique]
du coup oui alors je vous ai réservé une
petite surprise je me suis permis de le
convier quelques personnes j'ai pensé
que ce sera mieux pour votre vidéo ok
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on avait prévu
en fait à la base ne vous en faites pas
je les ai triés sur le volet elle adore
les énigmes et les casse têtes comme
vous et moi
radio ok bébé mais bonjour enchanté
salut je pense qu'on vous a expliqué du
coup je fais une vidéo dont vous allez
être filmé ça vous dérange pas j'espère
non non non pas du tout
je m'appelle les mains en fait je te
suis depuis super longtemps sur sa
chaîne je suis vraiment fan et tu dois
pas ton souvenir mais j'étais sur une de
tes vidéos matière grise oui mais si
cinéma je me souviens c'est très simple
tu sais que je m'appelle et me
c'est ouf un passé trop bien je suis
content d'être là ok du coup vous êtes
venus tous les trois ensemble j'imagine
et ballon
enfin pour une première prédiction de
mentalisme non mais c'est pas ça que je
voulais dire je voulais dire est ce que
vous connaissez les uns et les autres là
un nom je les connais pas et d'ailleurs
je vous connais pas non plus mais je
suis désolé je vous connais pas non plus
mieux niveau par contre anthony m'a dit
que vous étiez un expert donc enchantés
alors un expert je sais pas un passionné
ça c'est sur c'est quoi vos prénom du
coup moi c'est alors en chanter leurs
émois ces gens d'accord jean jack hockey
jacques du coup bah non jean-jacques
c'est un nom composé
voilà voilà je suis là
ces prêts à découvrir là où la magie
opère et pourtant ce n'est pas un bloc
opératoire
jeu juste avant grant est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui voudrait bien me filmer
pour que je filme mon arrivée
voilà un téléphone classique
[Musique]
et nous voilà arrivés dans notre pièce
phare vous allez être et blue hill vous
en prie approchez vous voilà n'ayez pas
peur l esi visualiser rapprochez vous
et voici le fameux cube de diamants dont
la valeur est estimée à environ un
million d'euros attention la vitrine été
remis à moudre aux quand même mais
pourquoi ça va autant ces diamants
d'autres experts du jour est là pour
nous l'expliqué fabien sauciflard
[Applaudissements]
au lit car
c'est assez incroyable c'est la première
fois que je suis aussi prêt que je le
voie pour de vrai comme ça l'or est ce
que ça vous dérange de me filmer comme
ça je vous explique et j'explique à la
caméra en même temps vous voulez que je
fais maintenant on voit les jeux steam
maintenant maintenant maintenant mais
moi je peux filmer ainsi si tu veux
alors comme ça vous me dites que vous
êtes prête
ok je vous l'avais promis le voici enfin
le casse-tête cubes de diamants créé par
la célèbre home ce qui a promis une
récompense d'un million d'euros à la
première personne qui sera capable de la
résoudre alors pourquoi un million
d'euros parce que la rumeur raconte
qu'elle aurait caché à l'intérieur un
diamant de cette valeur c'est plutôt
malin c'est pour bien compliqué et
quelle scanner le machin vieux verra
bien si
dans excellente comme marc jean jacques
mais évidemment vous n'êtes pas le
premier à penser à ça mais c'est très
bien ça me permet de rebondir sur votre
question en réalité la créatrice a
utilisé plein de types de matériaux
différents pour nous empêcher de voir si
à l'intérieur à l'aide d'un scanner du
type aux rayons x ou autre ensuite elle
a exposé un petit peu partout dans le
monde entier pour faire monter la sauce
comme on dit alors génie du marketing
philanthrope amoureuse de jeu et de
défis certains présentent comme ce comme
une millionnaire en manque de sensations
fortes il n'empêche que le mystère du
tube reste entier absolument absolument
il faut reconnaître que c'est cette part
de mystère qui fait tout le charme de
cet objet objets que vous pourrez
d'ailleurs retrouver à la boutique à
l'entrée du musée 1 aucune de ces
répliques ne vaut un million d'euros
bien évidemment
les approchez vous approchez vous voilà
pas trop quand même au cas où vous
déclenchez oriella larmes ça pourrait
vous la donner la larme à l'oeil très
larmes
le bruit tout ça
[Musique]
bon là
est fabien
tu penses que toi tu arriveras le
résoudre celui là est ce que tu penses
vraiment il ya un diamant à l'intérieur
je pense vraiment que c'est possible
mais après il faudrait pouvoir le
manipuler déjà up la caisse et surtout
ne bougez pas d'accord ne paniquez pas
monter cc c'est quoi c'est un happening
c'est encore une de vos bonnes idées
pour ma vidéo paniquez pas monsieur o
lietaer s'il vous plaît alors je vais
pas dire mais normalement quand un truc
comme ça arrive c'est jamais très nette
et puis je panique pas c'est juste je
comprends pas pourquoi il ya plus de
lumière étant donné que tu vas t'en va
pas bouger parce que j'ai peur du noir
ne paniquez pas je vous dis on ne
panique pas c'est vous qui paniquent et
qu'elle est vous que j'ai l'air de
paniquer est ce que j'ai l'air de
paniquer alors un petit peu
le cul le cubi les pédales qu il est
passé où le cube le cube a disparu
voilà voilà bravo la lépi nous le club
quelqu'un m'explique wilkie calmez vous
disant musée j'ai jamais vu ça on va pas
se mentir jean marc riebel il faut
récupérer ce qu on ne panique pas le
sommet s'est mobilisée en ne pas digne
malraux quand même façon on va pas se
mentir en souffrance ou faites-le qui
entoure ces chiens
le petit chat
alors
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
sur la police oui bonjour en fait on est
au musée et il a eu un braquage à un
million de dollars
comment ça quel musée en fait je vous
explique en fait on n'y avait que fabien
olicard mais c'est pas lui qui l'a volée
c'est sûr c'est juste qu'au bout du coup
est ce que vous pourriez venir s'il vous
plaît mais c'est très clair ce que je
dis mais je suis très calme puisque je
vous dis que je sais
à temps c'est pas ça qu'on cherche quoi
c'est pour ça qu'on cherche
a en fait c'est peut-être fabien olicard
mais moi je trouve ça un petit peu à
l'eau mais là aussi c'est un autre truc
là vous là pour la vidéo sammamish plus
- maintien oui bah tiens c'est non allez
on tue vous le remettez vous arrêter ça
je suis navré monsieur au placard mais
vous ne me laissez pas le choix je
pensais pas qu'on était intime au point
de s'attacher à la
con me dit ce qui se passe là c est quoi
ca ou lycéens profs vous avez une chaîne
youtube la du musée vous avez voulu
faire un peu de buzz aller où les
caméras là en plus ça sert à rien parce
qu'il peut défaire les noeuds alors déjà
je suis innocent et en plus je sais qui
est le coupable a laissé en moi j'en ai
entendu parler
c'est bon en plus ça peut pas et puis
c'est impossible oui enfin bon il était
quand même dans son sac en plus il était
juste à côté du cul quand l'avenir c'est
un bon jeu bien qu'aidé qui trop court
et moi j'étais à côté du tout du long
non mais vous êtes peut-être de match à
bourgoin peut-être mais non je suis pas
de mèche
ridicule chez l'une pharma décevez
beaucoup d'en prévenir les autorités
alors non seulement je suis innocent
mais je vous dire qu'il est coupable non
c'est bon il va nous manipuler j'ai déjà
vu star dans ces vidéos maintenant on va
commencer les explications par ça
comment vous pouvez savoir que je dis ça
dans mes vidéos puisque vous ne me
connaissiez pas
c'est lui c'est durable c'est juste et
vous c'est vous king il nous a dit des
trucs ou pas du tout mais si mais si
et vous est-ce que vous avez trouvé les
autres indices de la vidéo est ce que
vous savez qui est le coupable
alors sachez que je vais vous mettre
trois indices sur mes réseaux sociaux et
il y en aura d'autres sur les réseaux
sociaux de rhinau shield et je vous
donne rendez vous ici la semaine
prochaine pour la vidéo révélations sur
youtube ah et je m'appelle fabien
olicard je suis innocent rendez vous la
semaine prochaine ciao bien et monsieur
grotto cas
[Musique]